all right guys i am finally it's here
i'm going to be at caroline's on
broadway in new york city august 12th
through 14th i cannot wait to see you
there i'll be at the hartford funny bone
in connecticut august 27th through 28th
i'll be at
the zany's in chicago september 7th and
8th and then i'll be in cleveland ohio
at hilarity's september 9th through 11th
i have a bunch a bunch more dates coming
after that check them out on
annieletterman.com they're up now
hey guys i'm so excited to be on the
road i'm coming to portland november 3rd
at the helium comedy club and november
4th i'll be at cobbs in san francisco
and i'm coming to florida in october and
check out sleepover byaster.com for a
new drop of my clothing line
[Music]
hasn't ever pulled out like a like a
scary looking
number out of your ear out of the hole
where your thing is
no like you you dig your finger in your
ear in the hole
and you know the one yeah do you ever
pull something out that you wish you
hadn't seen i always wish i'd seen it
like it always so satisfactory to me
do you see something gross yeah it's ear
wax i just the way you set that up is as
though you have an extra ear hole you
don't want us to know about you're like
you know the one ear hole
well you are confusing me but have you
ever had that happen i thought you meant
like squeezing the juice out yeah but
not scary it's not like a worm comes out
but what so what is it then it's like a
satisfying chunk of earwax yeah it's
just been but it wasn't like dark and
scary yes but in a beautiful i probably
facetimed my loved ones and was like
yeah i had a good gun do you know that
asians have a different consistency um
ear wax than white people what are you
talking about does one of your ears have
white people wax and yeah so that's what
i've had this identity crisis not
because i don't know where i'm from but
because my earwax can't decide what they
are sometimes they're dry sometimes it's
wet because you guys would have a waxy
wetter earwax um asians have dry flakier
wax i thought i'd read that anyone can
have either
oh
what's going on here dude mosquitoes
are attracted to me
i think because i've dreamt of doing
this to you before it looks like someone
just gripped their fingers and yanked
you yeah no i know my meaty arms are
like yeah no guys can i just say well
let's just say on this side i think
we're very like classically
beautifully plumply thick right now
how could you see that look at her i'm
plumply thick beautifully classically
weak no we look good you're you just
called me fast well you want me to undo
what you said about yourself that's true
listen our arms are a little thicker no
my arm has always looked nine months
pregnant like it's just not my arm is
not okay well then i'm sorry what i said
about the rest of your body imagine
my arm i look back on when i was like
really fit before the pandemic and i am
actually not into the look at all yeah i
like all versions of myself i like a a
you know a season change like i'm not
against you know fluctuating before i
used to really care about the extra five
six pounds who gives a [ __ ] i look good
no matter what weight she's dealing with
five or six pounds you might be too
because of your height
there are like it's definitely in the
ranges of 10. wait i've hit i've
definitely gone 25 pounds over over my
normal before i know not now i am now
about 10 over do you think it's that
we're in our 30s and we're more
comfortable whereas like in your 20s
like every little body change like
scared me and i like had eating disorder
mindset but now it's like well you know
like you always say like i look fertile
like who cares
i don't know i think the fertile thing
really helps me but i because of that
but i also like i have like little
titties now
like a little bud yeah i honestly have
like i didn't get the full ones but i
when i look back at myself when i was
doing jiu jitsu and yoga and everything
all day i you can see the bones here
yeah and and the tits go i go too if
that's what makes you happy it's fine
but i honestly genuinely i'm attracted
to you in this shape well i was going to
say i go tits first into a diet but i
also want to say i'm attracted to you in
my outfit honestly i'm such a narcissist
i'm like she's never looked hotter
her accessories are gorgeous everyone
it's annie's birthday happy birthday
happy birthday to our ani and in honor
of that i have well let me tell you it
actually goes a lot further further the
the shirt just isn't piers i have fake
nipples underneath here that you can't
actually see they're bobby
they're bobbies they're bobby's you know
he he wears earbuds to sleep or those
ear waxy oh my god what if you stabbed
his expensive like i i like ipad
earbuds you're like yeah [ __ ] him he's
gone his radical 250s um so i have that
i actually tried to draw my abs that was
a decent can you show us your
attempt
it makes me feel so much better about
myself ew kala
what you know what she did though she
did give herself like the cut she gave
herself the v okay annie is i i knew
this i called this the first time annie
did her abs and i said it was there's
artistry amy is talented
and that's proof because you i can't do
it i can't it's but you're still kind of
bad too you look pretty hot in my outfit
well you want to know what happened i
had to i was praying enough time to get
[Music]
they look a little bit more like oh no
oh no
open in that root chakra baby
um i
i di i lost on the road i lost my
tube
what two do you usually use i use okay
ladies at home and by the way nyx you
owe me money for this okay
nyx wonder stick
this is the jam because you can get the
highlighter too the highlighter's key
you give it it really pops but i think
that
you should give yourself more credit you
know how to shape the app yeah
did you learn did you like i followed
where my abs like have were underneath
but did you like have to watch any
tutorial you just i watched some
tutorials you know i have 80d i can't
they take so long and they're like
subscribe and they like take so long to
get to it that i'm like all right i'm
gonna just drop myself
i can't wait for you to [ __ ] take
when i see like a like a makeup tutorial
and it's 11 minutes i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] this should be a two
minute video that's so funny because i
love the ones that are like 45 minutes
i just i'll just sit through the whole
thing like wow like she's so pretty and
then look at her
and then look at what she learned
no because i'm a makeup on the go girl
like i am a do it you're a go-go queen
on the makeup on the go-go
i take the little sperm and i do their
makeup well i have a question
today is a annie's birthday episode but
annie's birthday has already happened
and i'm curious what
what happened on your boat what'd you do
i
got let's just in a way i like to say
that i i tempted the delta virus i had a
real
i had a real let's see if this thing's
going to get me or not sorry and i'm
scared
don't worry weeks ago and i've been
tested several
but so okay so
no it didn't get me but
whitney randomly hit me up so my friend
was gonna throw me a surprise party and
i was like no thanks like i don't
it wasn't like gonna be it's like i
would like to control the people that
are my if i'm gonna have a party but i
also don't want a party i have a no
surprise party policy well yeah you have
a no surprise yeah party
but don't you think i was onto something
you didn't want it we had a great
episode for you that you seemed
miserable the whole time which one we
gave you the wheelchair oh god
by the way i'm gonna start just using a
wheelchair
why not i mean look if you if
i don't think there's anyone to tell you
like that if you have chronic fatigue
which i think esther has yeah cancer has
something to do or like low blood
pressure
low blood pressure i do have low blood
pressure yeah um i'm so proud i'm yeah
but do you really think i have chronic
fatigue
from like you told me did you miss me i
feel like
do you think i have it am i being
diagnosed i for sure have it and because
like is this esther's birthday we can't
diagnose her on my birthday we can't
give her her dreams
i've never seen a happier girl are you
diagnosing me with something like that
one you could really milk too chronic
fatigue
i can't make it
i'm too tired i can't make it over to
that bowl can you put popcorn in it for
me
i've always self-diagnosed myself with
some type of like
hypotensive issue where it's it's called
pots
um
what is happening
it's kind of like it's like this
autonomia it's weird my blood pressure
gets low it's a collection of things
that uh that that my symptoms match but
i think you have some weird chronic
fatigue i would say the weird chronic
this is the rudest thing anyone says no
i mean i stop them why are you grinning
and
looking like you're taking go-go right
now
i've never seen a girl this happy since
she was taking gum shots
[Laughter]
um by the way if can i tell you where
we're different we're alike in a lot of
ways yeah i would try my hardest in life
to not be diagnosed with something
called pots i would be like i would
change my entire life to not have
whatever look i don't know if i have
pots but i for sure have um
um orthostatic hypotension so for
instance
you guys i passed out um in a yoga class
last week on a camel pose she has
[ __ ] covered no
will knock you out though it knocked me
the [ __ ] you know how you're supposed to
do it's you do the camel pose annie
yes ma'am so
yeah is it that
but do it slowly because you will pass
up something broke just now in your body
yeah but so you're hanging on to your
ankles here i'll do it oh [ __ ] i can't
do this i'll do it oh i know you like
this yeah
oh my god this is the one i skipped when
i was doing bikram i cannot do this okay
so i passed out in camel pose because i
have um have you ever imagined a stream
of [ __ ] coming on you annie drop it
also
you passed out during your life
i swear to god
the lights went out in the city but did
people notice you passed out or you wake
up well my sister was right next to me
and apparently like i came back to it
because and then my eyes were in
completely different directions we've
heard we've heard about this wandering
eye
but usually it goes inward goes out of
town and all of a sudden the eyes are
wandering
and so i it took me about a minute to
come around and i was really impressed
there was the whole class standing over
you did you wake up like this
and then everyone was standing over here
no no one even noticed i was out that
was that saddest part about it no one
came to my aid that's like when i ran
away from home and nobody knew and i
just had to come home was it recently
that's weird
i was little wait do you ever threaten
like you ever like pack your like during
a fight pack your bags and threaten to
leave
not really do you guys no i don't make
fake threats i've i learned that lesson
a long time ago guys
you put a poison in the well when you do
that that's so true you cannot like if i
get married i realize like i can just
never say the divorce word the divorce
the d word you cannot
what is the divorce word the divorce
word is um i can't say it it's actually
will get me canceled but i had a guy do
that to me he was a visiting lover from
australia and he thought we were a lot
more serious we probably were pretty
serious but every day i would come home
and he'd probably write a text or
something and every day he he packed his
back like for like three weeks straight
every day he had his bags back i hate
when you date someone long distance and
then they come visit you and then you
realize you absolutely hate their
[ __ ] guts and then everything they
say you hate you're like oh you're so
[ __ ] you know and especially like an
accent you're like that you think is hot
um
um and then so once it's in your ear all
the time you're like i [ __ ] hate this
accent it's so funny that annie says
she's like don't you hate it when like
this has happened multiple times
we have to get back to you yoga pass out
this is my fault well nothing happened
except that the lights went out in the
city you guys and no one was there to
help you no one noticed what city is it
new jersey city over here it went out in
waikiki
oh yeah you were in hawaii right yeah
why did everyone have a better birthday
than me wait where were you i agree with
you from hawaii no i will say this i
went to i did go to i went to vegas
and it was todd and i i'm telling you if
i had gotten it it would have been
[ __ ] worth it oh my god no listen no
i'm saying this 100 you're gonna
understand what i tell you the views are
expressed by annie letterman do not
reflect
the collective worth
listen
todd and i were in the casino and i got
like 500 bucks in cash out and i just
said this is our gambling money what
casino we were well we stayed at the
sahara which is like pretty guts
and then the and then we went to the
wind but the problem with when you go to
the nice ones the minimums are so high
that it's not fun to play right like you
don't it's like you don't want to run
out of your money right away yeah but
todd and i went back to the other one
and we were like i had to i had just
gotten hypnotized to stop smoking
cigarettes but there was a mother and
son from brooklyn
that i would have been chained smoking
hundred newports
um
newport hundreds with like
i was looking at the cigarettes going
like literally this time yesterday i
would have been
like smoked that lady's back it was so
fun yeah
being hypnotized worse i've been getting
hypnotized on everything tell us more
about that well let me get through let
me tell you about the epic birthday yeah
todd and i found my favorite machine my
favorite uh slot machine was this veno
white vanna white she would appear there
were three different wheels it was the
most exciting bonuses bonuses like it
was just incredible then i go and i'm
asking like where's the thing and
they're like oh that doesn't exist i was
like it's just too good they had to take
it from us
so then i'm like ugh but then i was like
you know what you got to be positive
there's going to be another one that's
good like that family guy so we find i
didn't try the family guy one but we
tried we did a walking if you like
family guy it's great you look like
stewie has anyone told you i i want to
be stewie that's like my first
character the whole thing
except he's better at accents than you
who are you
i'm the um
don't know quagmire the neighbor yeah
we both knew
okay i'm like the annoying one i don't
know
um with a great name but so we're like
what i'm a little yeah you're lowest
like we're all trying to [ __ ] you or oh
oh
what i'm a lois i think
what's the daughter where's the daughter
meg mag be mad no at least we all know
i'm meg okay you can't be all of them
it's no one wants okay
that
guys i'm posh and you literally can't do
anything about it
you can't unposh me look at you you're
sporty
do not call me the lesbian one she's not
the lesbian one she's the only one that
can really
why did your lips get so like they were
eating a girl out when you said that
go to the vegas story
so we play a walking dead game that's
pretty fun i'm like okay all right this
is good
we move on
we get to we're passing by a crazy rich
asians game and i say listen my girl
nora aquafina that's my [ __ ] homegirl
my boyfriend's half asian my my people
are asian sorry
everyone i like is asian um but so
we sit down and play it and it's
i've never had more fun in my life like
i'm gonna cry tears of joy in front of
us
we were screaming people were behind us
like we were like oh my god like scream
people were like go go oh you're getting
our money that should be ours like we
made we made like three hundred dollars
there's like these little like
these little diamonds that you get that
give you bonuses it's like ding ding
ding ding and then it's just like you
know like they whenever they're like
ding ding ding
and it's like you're making like it's
like 20 bucks like for like they're like
big money and it's being 20 but you're
like it's just giving you everything you
want because it's just trained to make
your brain feel that adrenaline we were
so happy we were screaming we were up
like we had made 300 and then we brought
it back down to 200 and i was like all
right we got to go because we're
starting to lose again
so todd goes to play roulette which is
my now my other favorite game
goes to play roulette with the mother
son from brooklyn who oh my god
you guys it was like so amazing it was
this black guy with a butthole surfer
shirt on and i was like and he goes he
goes yeah i saw them in uh in brooklyn
it was just like the most amazing
it was just like worlds colliding like
everything was like incredible that is
very that's a that's the ultimate vegas
vibe yeah it was unbelievable his mother
was like wasted and she didn't know how
to play and she kept like trying to
touch the um
the dealer it was just so good it was
like they had to leave for their flight
they were like oh we only had 45 minutes
of our flight
i was like that is so vegas
so then we go
todd goes to play roulette i go to the
bathroom and i go you know what
ah i just feel like there's one a couple
more pushes i gotta make so i go out to
finish business i was i'm not done i go
i go back to the um walking dead
and there had been this white [ __ ] that
was coming up i don't watch the show and
she never made you any money and i was
like eventually this way but just making
me money i pushed it twice the whole
thing was the swipe bitch's face and
then it was like times four and i was
like ding ding ding i made 200
wow and then i just took it out and went
over and we played roulette so we left
we were like 300 up when we left
that sounds like the best night ever it
was so fun wow but just the gate like
falling if you just lean into the fact
that this is
meant to make you feel the way it's
feeling yeah but i go behind people like
hype people behind theirs and like yeah
one of the guys we were laughing about
how little the amount is but it's still
so fun to watch maybe you're a warmer
you know how there's a cooler is that
the opposite a cooler is somebody who
adjoins a table and basically um ruins
the chances at the table have you seen
that movie with
it
um but maybe you're somebody you're the
opposite of that she's a warmer but
she's also cold so we have to get her
sweater
attention to all men across the galaxy
and all the way from australia to
houston
do you have a pube problem
i like the way you asked that if so our
friends at manscaped have cleared you
for takeoff with their fourth generation
and brand new lawnmower 4.0 kick your
pubes to the next planet with a
performance package 4.0 the orbits in
his pants will feel like they're in zero
gravity when he uses the best tools for
the job from the leaders in male
grooming listen this is a nasa theme
thing we don't need to have an asta
pubes and inside the package you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer we might need
that
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold his whole solar
system the lawnmower 4.0 also has a
4000k led spotlight that you can turn on
and off when needed for a more precise
shave throughout your travels across the
universe this led light is literally a
genius move i'm so glad we have it you
guys this has taken off not only in the
usa but canada the uk across europe
australia south africa and singapore can
you believe everyone has pubes
we all over here at trash tuesday are
obsessed with our manscaped and you guys
can get 20 off plus free shipping with
the code trash at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trash manscape.com
men aboard hairy balls and buzz
lightyear your woody with manscape his
spaceballs will thank you
hey annie and kalyla you know what's
something that all three of us need
really bad
therapy better help bobby and i've been
using betterhelp for years and not only
has it it's just improved every aspect
of my life i think that even if you're
not going through a crisis it's good to
keep you know the maintenance the grass
in your pastures green
and it's always good to talk out your
week with somebody
so if there's something preventing you
from achieving your goals better help is
the way to go we are obsessed with
better help they have a journal feature
where i can just write out my feelings
and what i'm dealing with and just
whenever i feel like it and my licensed
therapist will check it out and also
what i love about it is 48 hours from
now you can be communicating with
someone who's helping you and it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in depression stress anxiety
trauma
that's all of us anger family conflicts
lgbt matters and the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
find the particular expertise you need
online you don't need to limit yourself
to the counselors located near you and
do not worry you guys anything you share
is confidential and this betterhelp is
so convenient professional and
affordable they have so many
testimonials on their site and it's not
a crisis line this is the real deal
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
we want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
10 percent off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people have taken charge of their mental
health again that's
betterhelphelp.com trash tuesday there's
nothing more important i'm sorry than
your mental health nothing
but there was like a movie it was a
movie called the calendars or no the
cooler
but it's about vegas and it's like if
you want the table like the the casino
hired her to approach a table to sort of
cool the table when it's a little too
hot how could nursing school doesn't
work out yes
how does how could you actively cool a
table down like that's what i don't
understand well if it's if there's like
maybe if they're just like on a run you
add one more person then okay the good
cards go out my dad recently went to
vegas and he told me that so he he was
playing poker and i guess when you play
poker at the table who's at the bellagio
you hand everyone your like players card
which has your name on it so like the
dealer gets all the players cards goes
through some whatever and my dad's
sitting there at the table and the the
dealer goes
mori p and my dad's like yeah
and he's like hey
and it's a guy that my dad went to high
school with and played cards with and my
dad's 78 years old it's like how what
are the chances and it i was just like
that's crazy like that would have been
you should have gone and put money like
on black you should have been like i'm
putting all my money on black lives i
thought the story was gonna go
completely different way when they
started kissing no i thought he was
gonna be mistaken for mari povich
maury p
well he my dad can only go to several
like he can't go to there's a certain
like parent company i don't know if it's
mgm or which one he can't go to any of
their casinos because he banned himself
oh good that's your girl oh you can ban
yourself yeah you can blacklist you my
dad did the same thing he did yeah
all over because he lost most of his
money gambling because he was one of
those yeah bad gambling it's just it the
thing is because the fun is in the
continuing to do it it really isn't
burning yeah if you can like you would
probably be great at it because i could
see you just taking the money and going
yeah but it's like i
i was much better on this trip than i
ever have been like where it's like i
could feel myself okay i'm going into
the dark zone like obviously we've had
enough fun hey what's the dark zone it's
just when you know it's stopped giving
you the good stuff because it sucks you
in like that yeah the machine's like
it's not fun anymore well the machines
are gonna give you a lot of like bonuses
and wins but
like after a while they cool it it cools
the i don't know the terminology that's
what happened to me and i know it's a
different island different place but
that's what happened to me in hawaii so
everything closes down there at 12
because of kovit and what not but i went
to a bar for the first time in like two
years i had two drinks and the rest of
the night i was in every single uber
looking for strip club
looking for an open strip club why
esther does that sober because i think
that i've been
like in this space for so long that when
i had my first drink it was like a
nostalgic i'm in vegas feeling like i'm
out with my friends let's let's just it
doesn't end here yeah it's morning the
night you know well sometimes it is it's
like why would we just go to bed now
there's more to be had i will say since
you said what you just said that one
time me and dave went to a strip club in
santa barbara
and you slid off the chair
you suck
too much you suck
no we went to strip club and like dave
was like
i feel like you're enjoying like dave
was like weirded out dave you do have
long hair like i'm just saying like your
hair is a little
she's a dragon i feel like he felt like
i liked it too much like i i just
thought there was that was in the air i
hope he doesn't watch this
podcast well sometimes he does the other
day he sent me like a little screenshot
of because you know how the
producers will add like
little like it says it labels the chunk
of like this system we're talking about
your clubs there was one chunk that was
labeled like dave's sleep apnea mask
he was like great
wait okay we keep teasing a vegas trip
is it actually gonna happen we have to
do it are you kidding yeah like how yes
i wanna go so bad we gotta see usher i
also have a dream
guys i have a dream hold on it's not a
team decision i'm not sure i'll leave
you guys i'll come back i wanna do
washer are you kidding me
katy perry let's do both one night one
night
is she back she's coming in the december
i think she starts waiting because i
want to do it
even if it's like i just see like a shot
on your head
i've never had more fun i realize i come
alive they're they're in miami i brought
my miami out by the way
i will say that vegas in the winter
starts to die down what do you mean just
the vibe is not as fun so it's got to be
late september or sometime in the next
two months or i'm out okay well don't
threaten us i'll take the thing i'm
threatening that was my life
also my winter body is not i'm not
primed for vegas activity i'm going to
the desert to do drugs with ducks
crew again at the very end of september
oh okay we'll have to do it well it's
close enough to vegas is it death valley
yeah okay we can make it a little bit
well i could also do
we don't need much time right like we
could go friday night to sunday night i
do want to watch a show though so
annie's right i do want to see usher i
want to get backstage at chris angel i'm
just saying that i'm putting that out
there into the universe and i will be
like chris angel do you want to see a
trick
i'm now behind the curtain
i'm now backstage
did you grow up to chris angel a little
bit but it's more just like i don't i'm
no longer i no longer want to just be an
innocent bystander i want to be like
listen have you heard of podcasts well
we've got one we need to be backstage
okay
i feel like there's other places i'd
rather go backstage like before chris
angel is it getting a pedicure because
you're fingering your
crusty toes i don't get pedicures they
make me uncomfortable yeah we can see do
you get them yes i don't at all i've
never i haven't had a pedicure in
eight years i think it's like creepy
like feet are like tools they're not
meant to be tools to what to walk to
make men
not for me are you sure to walk astray
because you're you're also a wheelchair
queen all right
you know what we need to get you we need
to get you those heelies the shoes with
wheels
i want those
no i've always likes looked at those
like wow like what would that be like
can you imagine she forgets she has them
and goes to get in her car
right down the [ __ ] hill wait annie
i need to hear about this hypnotizing
thing like are you really telling me
that you got hypnotized and you it made
you quit do you feel sleepy
um yeah
tell us more like and i honestly also
think it's the reason i didn't get um
covered the view is expressed by annie
letterman no i think i made myself like
immune
like i'm like my immune system well i
think it could be the vaccine
i do think that there's something to
what you're saying it's like if you
don't carry that stress in your life
your immune system is automatically
boosted so 100
so there is you know it's a combination
she's vaccinated she's in a better place
and her immune system is joyful and
light
i just was like my family's healthy i'm
healthy yeah but um you know i got i've
gotten
uh hypnotized for that i did a hypnosis
today that was like sexual trauma
hypnosis that was
i had some crazy
epiphanies really and i gotta go in
again and do it again but
it was she had me like go back over my
timeline of my life and see like
like i envisioned it like um
an ekg is that what it's called like the
heart yeah like like a line like that
and i was like floating over it and then
i would see like dark spots and then i
would go to them and i had this like
memory
of there was this guy jack who used to
come to my parents house like so dark i
really jumped into this from vegas
but um
that you took into my house and i always
like thought he might have molested me
because he would he would chase me he
would like tickle me and chase me into
this closet as his memory always had but
he was only at my house two times when i
was like four or whatever so it's like
this like misty memory
and in the hypnosis today i was like
what happened what happened i think i
either like bit him or yelled at him
because
i was thinking about it every and and
all of my like sexual assaults like my
three or four that i had makes me sound
so histrionic i swear to god i'm not a
liar but um
i always told i always like got them in
trouble they always were fired i always
went to court i never ever ever like
didn't
like avenge it so i'm like why would
this have been a time that i didn't and
i was like i think i i told him to get
away from me because
also he didn't come back so he came
twice the the second time was the
chasing man oh yeah you were a biter i
told him i got his [ __ ] ass out yeah
is this something you didn't know about
until you just did this i had the memory
of the closet but i didn't really know
what happened i kind of was like who
[ __ ] cares
i really need another one
who gives a [ __ ] but it was cool to be
able to like so she takes you back and
like you go through these these
situations and then you think of like
the positive thing that happened from it
like the lesson you learned from it and
then you just focus on that and then you
like deflate whatever the bad emotion is
like you physically like
like release the air from it and then
you just put light into it and then your
your lifeline just has all these like
bright light spots now instead of the
dark ones oh i like that yeah it was
really sweet and when they put you like
do they actually do the like you're
getting no it's a it's like you're you
talk over zoom so the way that i've been
doing it is like you talk over zoom
and you tell her like whatever you're
dealing with
and then she's like well what does your
show goes what does your beautiful brain
need to hear
and then so you
so if i'm worried about
like um ticket sales or something if i'm
like i'm worried about ticket sales like
instead of that i should be like i'm
really like happy to perform rather than
focusing on that or i don't know if
that's the right example
but so then you know you're just like
putting stuff into your head yeah you're
also just replacing the other feeling
right the negative feeling with
something yeah good one yeah yeah but
it's cool it's like been really awesome
but um i wanted to talk to you annie you
mentioned something about um your family
vacation and how
it didn't go um as smoothly this time
around
well my brother
my older brother just got this house in
new jersey and he's like everyone stay
with me
and we're like okay i was like i can get
a hotel i actually have enough money for
a hotel and i don't have to sleep on a
couch even though i do like getting
woken up by the kids it's fun no
so i do like that and we also like the
family hangs out we smoke a little weed
not me because i don't do that anymore
but
oh you quit smoking pot sometimes okay
sometimes i've been out but this time i
didn't smoke
every once a month i do yes every few
days
but um
occasionally i dabble in quitting
smoking weed but i had been smoking
cigarettes a lot and she completely
cleared that it was so cool and my
[ __ ] tmj dude i'm not clinch i swear
to god i'm not clenching my jaw and she
put into my brain that i my jaw is
relaxed while i'm sleeping no i swear to
god well esther and i might be going on
a trek because we're just in so much
pain you're gonna go to the botox well
here's the thing i don't want to get
botox on my jaw because i'm afraid of
losing my big fat cheeks
i love the shape of my face i don't want
to change anything about the shape of my
face but my doctor did say there's a
chance that you can only need it once
and just break the habit of clenching
all together that he's had patients only
need it once or twice and that's it but
i just have a fear of getting you know
because i like my cheeks and i don't
like i mean if you're bringing that
botox noodle near me
a lot of the chances i'm not like come
on give me a little
lift your arms i'm like come on i gotta
try to cure this next my sweaty armpits
but that's amazing so you're not
clenching it's like i mean it's better
by like
over 50 like it's like crazy i recently
had someone which you're the first
person who told me about this
where they go in your mouth that's good
right it's so
masseuser like a bodywork guy puts his
hands in my mouth it is amazing let's
stop going to guys but anyway
no more boys
they go in your mouth they take your
their penis and they get yourself no no
no no
can i can i show you guys the nipples
that i'm using
yes
hold on i think i click
look is it not the close to your color
oh i love that
yeah
here oh does he do that to not hear
things yeah he doesn't want to hear or
yeah anything
he's a [ __ ] yapper oh my god
oh my god bobby bobby does my head in he
really won't shut the [ __ ] up sometimes
he always has to have an opinion i'm
more of a uh quiet let's just get things
done around the house
about it later
annie what i wanted to get to was your
my fight with my brother no no no you
realizing that you were a fat family
oh we went swimming yeah we went
swimming
and it was actually the most fun so we
went to like the like my brother's a
member of the pool
and there was really not anyone there so
it was just like we had the pool and we
were pool kids like we used to walk to
the pool every day and hang out the pool
all day so me and my two brothers
put all push in 40s 140 already
like diving off the diving board like we
are [ __ ] seven years old like we were
i was doing a back dive or do other
stuff but my sister-in-law gave me a one
piece to wear because i only have like
the horious the strength
just ass cheeks out
and
um so i was wearing my sister-in-law's
swimsuit and it was just
i mean there were pictures and i was
like oh my god like we are you don't
have to have a kid to have a mama's body
it turns out
and we it just i just was like looking
at my feeling like we are we're we're
fat family now we can't like your
brothers we are none of us like usually
there's one that's like
fit like we are all
we got coveted let's just say that you
got
or 19 whatever it is
but they're such a joy in just accepting
yeah like kids
i'm like i look great for a mother of
two look amazing in that swimsuit it was
like i was the hottest mother of two
sometimes i do want to tell people i'm
45 just to hear the compliment of saying
no wow you know what always happens when
you do that they go oh my god you only
look 44 and then you're like what i was
like i'm 36. it always backfires
you're right but not that i'm fat not
that my family's mad guys it was just
the thing i said um but so we then my
okay so we always do these themed photos
or we have in the past me and my family
and this one we were gonna do the kids
dress up like adults and the adults
dress up like kids but at this point
there's so many people in the family now
it's stressful to do and it's now my mom
has like hijacked it it was like a thing
i did for my instagram because i have
followers and my mom now is like we need
to do my picture it's like nobody cares
about your mom but um i love you i love
my mom
um but so
we're like getting this whole thing
together i black my two teeth out put my
hair in pigtails
my brother is wearing like a cowboy
shirt and a cowboy hat
and he just starts yelling at me and i
just lose it i start yelling back at him
and i didn't even realize until today
that we were in these costumes and we
were yelling i'm like if there's footage
of that fight
i mean we were like going at each other
what was the fight he goes he was trying
to figure out like where the kids were
going to stand and he just started
yelling at me and going you have no
respect for my things
i'm like timmy is this from fourth grade
because i literally i'm just here taking
care of it and having fun with your kids
i've done nothing i didn't was not like
no respect for my face i'm like for what
the hell are you talking about and he
was like screaming at me and then he
didn't realize he yelled at me and my
sister-in-law not his wife my other
sister-in-law had to be like
no tim you started that that was crazy
you came out of nowhere she didn't do
anything i was like yes [ __ ] this is
what having a sister's like this is
awesome that is not what having a sister
is like
it is just to be clear
if you have a sister that's close enough
in age like it's it's the best i cannot
describe to you how lucky i feel that i
have a sister only a year older than me
that is cool it is like a warm blanket i
think you just know like you just know
that life can never suck as long as her
sister always says she's like a wet
blanket
my sister i view her more as like my
abuser like
just tortured me my whole childhood it
wasn't so
nice on her end
the helper
was she was seven years old put to work
this year
is that what happened did she have to
care for you a lot of times she had she
was a helper yeah yeah that's that's
rough on a kid but she i think she she
liked it like she she we had our good
moments but you know there was also the
rough stages where she was torturing me
fully and i love her and i was sitting
outside the door out of the door closed
door of her room crying screaming
begging to get in i wasn't allowed in
i've been there too with esther everyone
goes
let me
i love the sponsor so much you guys
don't let the stress of daily life weigh
on your body whether you're an elite
athlete like kalila or someone like me
and annie just trying to make it through
the day tension free
the theragun can help theragun is a
handheld percussive therapy device that
releases your deepest muscle tension
using a scientifically calibrated combo
of depth speed and power and it's as
quiet as an electric toothbrush the gen
4 theragun doesn't just feel good it
gets to the source of the pain by
releasing tension using theragon's
signature percussion therapy which goes
60 deeper than vibration alone you know
what i love i love the different
attachments
for the different parts
for your face
freaking face love it that's the best
one
the oled screen and design make you feel
like you're holding something from the
future just go to their site and check
it out and the theragan app learns from
your behaviors and suggests guided
routines whether you want to treat your
muscle tension from working now an
injury or just the stresses of everyday
life there is no substitute for the
theragon gen4 theragan is trusted by 250
professional sports teams like real
madrid and elite athletes like paul
george dion deandre hopkins maria
sharapova and hundreds of thousands of
customers and me
and esther and annie no but you guys
know how it feels when you have a really
tense jaw or like a tense neck and then
the feeling after you've used the
theragun you just feel lighter and
easier i will say after my most
difficult like um workout days this cuts
my recovery in half try theragon for 30
days starting at only 199 go to
therabody.com
trash tuesday right now and get your gen
for theragun today that's therabody.com
trash tuesday
therabody.com trash tuesday we are
obsessed with our farrah guns wait annie
is your ex still using your netflix
password because that's what one woman
found out after she downloaded trueball
which finds and cancels subscriptions
with just a tap i mean is that not
enough to get it no the day of the
pandemic i was like change all passwords
bye sorry
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about which is my biggest
problem oh i get a ding and i go i'm
like oh i'll look at that later and then
it's like you look at your bill and
you're like that was
it's so much money it's crazy
so crazy no when i got true bill
honestly the it was an entire list of
[ __ ] i did not know i was spending a ton
of time it's so sad how much is workout
stuff too what gets you is like you
agree to like a seven day subscription
free right and then it dings you and
then you just forget i have so many of
those it's so bad like i true bill has
hooked me
up also on average people save up to 720
a year with true bill but me no mine's
way higher than me yeah
i believe
i genuinely believe that you guys
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel true bill makes it incredibly
simple just link your accounts and
drupal will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in one tab and your true
bill concierge is there when you need
them to cancel unwanted subscriptions so
you don't have to you guys don't fall
for subscription scams start canceling
today at truebill.com trash tuesday go
right now truebill.com
trash tuesday could save you thousands a
year and you'll have so much fun seeing
what you've been up to do you know many
how many tops at zara you could have
bought for 720p
is all i'm thinking about yeah i'm
thinking of sushi
esther so i want to talk about your
mosquito bites do you think you have
skeeter syndrome what's that
that's
she's so happy this is the secret i'm
just throwing diagnosis at you because i
know they make you happy thank you
skeeter syndrome refers to significant
allergic reaction to a mosquito bite
so it's not like you get bitten more you
and i probably get bit the same you just
have a bigger reaction to the bite so
you get like big does this make her have
a bigger reaction to everything this is
gonna be what she has i actually feel
very confident i don't have this because
this says you have a very you're very
sensitive to the bites and you may
develop a fever i have to say i am that
i was always that kid that showed up to
school covered in bites my legs like i'm
always covered covered so many more than
everyone else
and i feel completely sweet blood they
call you that i just had chickenpox she
was just giving everyone [ __ ]
chickenpox
that's a good name for a sweet blood
sweet blood
but i was gonna say my best friend has
skeeter syndrome and when she gets bit
by even a single you know pats and
skeeter together this is really hard and
i'm just saying that the team you guys
have so hers gets like it's a giant
boiled egg and she does get a fever wow
like the size of her mosquito bites are
like this big oh it's really sad my um
nieces get like not like that big but
they do get bigger than usual but she
doesn't get a fever or anything uh so
you told me a story about your ballet
teacher the other day
uh it's gonna be so different than our
teacher stories it's well i don't know
it's not great
this was so i started taking ballet
class again like the last couple weeks
just like for therapy you know mental
this is a current teacher no no just
wait is it because of the olympic year
you thought that you'd make a comeback
no i was like you know i had a little
health thing and i was like okay you
know what i couldn't really work out for
a little bit i was like was your health
thing for uh the past 20 years yes
i feel like in that joke you assumed i
was only 20 years old
i was imagining i knew you for 20 years
um
so i got i was like you know what i'm
gonna take advantage i'm feeling better
i'm gonna take ballet class so i've been
going to ballet and it's been really
fair like therapy it's been really fun
but it there was this one ballet class
that i looked up and i was like i can't
go back to that one
because the last time i went there
i took the class it was it was great at
night the kids mean to you in the class
no this is an adult class i just imagine
you as the only adult in a child oh i've
done that too
i've done that too that's how you look
good they're better
so i take the class and i really like
the teacher and at the end of the class
like i you know i always go up and thank
the teacher maybe strike up her
conversation she's like you look really
familiar and i was like oh
yeah yeah you know the foo fighters
i was like oh you know i'm a comedian
she's like oh yeah
i'm like what and she's like um
i
it's so bad i'm just gonna tell you
basically who she was she remembered me
because about seven years earlier i sent
her a message on facebook saying you
work at starbucks with my boyfriend and
i think you that you don't know he has a
girlfriend
and i think that he and him are hooking
up so why don't you tell me if you are
or not
because i used to be a [ __ ] psycho
and dave no no someone else someone else
so i was dating a guy who had a
part-time job at starbucks
red robin and starbucks i mean these
we're getting some deposits bottomless
fries i love red robin
and
i was so embarrassed i was like i am so
sorry well how like sure were you like
that she was going to be like oh my god
here i love your standoff wow i love
your comic central special
thank god this is a little before that
but but
yeah like it just goes to show like that
girl that you're dming because you think
she's hooking up with your boyfriend
might be your ballet teacher seven years
later did she was she hooking up with
him i actually still don't know by the
time that this we met i really didn't
care thank god
but i
this guy i was dating i think was like
cheating on me quite a bit
and i have
i don't know the fat one or the skinny
one i'm not people will know so i'm not
even i know that
wait on behalf of my lovely exes [ __ ]
you those two are not lovely listen we
like them they're our friends they're
not lovely i actually still don't know
what he was up to wait did you ask her
what do you care to know if you did or
not now i don't care at all yeah i know
i don't care at all because i'm best
friends with one of my exes when i was
17 and i'm like i like literally like
we're really good friends and we spear
fish together all of these things he's
married i love his wife is he the one
that um i'm at that was
no no no he's he's like you have hot
friends dude i do they're married and
hot
they are they're married and hot i mean
i'm with a very hot yeah yeah yeah but
um but this particular guy um
i dated him from 17 to 20.
and when we talk about his time in his
life he always like we
he always reveals something new to me
that i didn't know back then and it's
always like wait when did that happen
and he's like oh this is i [ __ ] this
girl then i was like we were together
he's like oh yeah sorry dude are you
sure but it doesn't bother me at all it
doesn't bother me now clearly because
it's like who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't
change anything
but it does make me wonder like how much
do i know about
every single person i i've dated in the
past because i've always just had trust
yeah
because of what's happened i've never
had trust and it took probably two years
of like not trusting dave and going
through his phone and reading all his
old facebook messages before i'm like
okay like now i know we're like this is
so boring i'm like yeah so many story
lines oh another storyline for another
episode
now i know what trust is but before that
i literally didn't know what it felt
like to trust someone wait so esther are
you ever going to ask her
i'm let's call her no
i've got her on the line because i am
too embarrassed to go back to her class
you should go back to our cousin [ __ ]
was the class good
yeah it was ballot but then go back but
like i she knows this embarrassing thing
about everybody did you apologize did
you apologize i did of course i yeah i i
was totally like i'm oh my god i'm so
embarrassed i'm so sorry but also maybe
she him and if that's the case i want to
say on behalf of everyone i'm so sorry
that's horrible that you went through
that with that guy
but but if she did that's it's not her
bad it's his bad no i know she's
innocent right if she had sex with her
because you're saying you didn't know
that she didn't know yeah then why don't
we just if we're still friends with the
ex just ask him so and so i took a
ballet class and this is her did you
bang her did you ever hang did you hook
up with that girl at starbucks yeah we
need to know now i need to know oh my
god i'll ask that because even if it's a
yes
i don't think he'll he'll be honest with
me even now i don't think he's gonna
want to admit that he was cheating on me
i don't think it's kind of cool in
retrospect that he cheated on you though
why i don't know i got away with
something
i mean we broke up like right soon out
he dumped my ass i will say annie is
right in the sense that he out did your
spy work and you're a really nice guy
thank you you're a great guy how did he
out do my spy work excuse me because you
still don't know the answer oh because i
didn't
i dumped your ass you didn't get to find
out i didn't dumped you
did he dump you you're into the i don't
know i don't know that you care about
the actual information you're just like
the spine i like the chase the hunter
your dad your dad this is like your dad
right you guys learned how to be yeah
kind of yeah
just i'm a researcher yeah
i'm a detective yeah in college i loved
doing the research for papers i never
liked writing them so then i passed it
off to my mom
so now it's your turn mother
but i used to love going to like the i
would go have to go to the libraries in
like albuquerque which is an hour away
from santa fe and i go into the basement
like you're like dusting off like
the books like go oh well now i'm going
to go to this boy and then i was like
what am i do i don't even he's like i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah i might even
write the show but i will ask him
yeah i get i don't yeah why not
i think it's worth it i think that our
audience deserves an answer i'll report
back because maybe that girl was like oh
[ __ ] yeah i did my bad or maybe she's
just like this crazy girl dm me and
nothing i never did anything that's how
i found out about a next cheating on me
i just asked her straight up like this
is what i think was your ex a girl see
if that's me with us
so
my ex cheated on me with a tattoo client
and um
i
i got suspicious and i asked her i was
like did you sleep with my boyfriend and
she was a really nice lady she was a
teacher she said yeah she said that you
guys were broken up and then that's it i
got my answer wow i had a girl
who dated my ex-boyfriend like
right after we broke up but i had been
in this three-year relationship i didn't
want to be in so like
for three years oh it was supposed to be
two months i was like
which one was this do i know it the
rollerblader
oh yeah
do you remember earlier it should have
been two months this is when we this was
when we were live
i had to go to a elementary school so he
could skate the
kids park or whatever did you have to
roll her blade with him i do love
rollerblading by the way i can't knock
grow listen now that i now as an elder
person
an elder
in this world
i would rollerblade
that's fun i have yeah but yeah it was
his whole thing yeah yeah it wasn't like
it can't be your whole thing yeah he was
30. it was like you didn't if you could
make it with roadblock which i'm not
sure you can you didn't you didn't make
it well so there's a reason why
rollerblading is not in the olympics but
it was a little bit hard
he was good he could do all the tricks
and stuff but it was just like it was so
funny to be a comedian dating a
rollerblader
and i would sometimes just say that on
stage and everyone would just laugh i'm
like oh i didn't even tell a joke i just
told you like what he is
[Music]
damn is that why it went on longer than
i should have yes well he kept skating
away i was trying to break up with him
he'd roll off yeah because it was funny
i was like you're giving me too many
bunch
you guys
so i just it occurred to me that
we're not the original slugs excuse me
i know well
jules you know applied to all of these
colleges and she got into certain uc
schools but do you know that uc santa
cruz are the banana slugs are you
serious yeah that's their [ __ ]
what do you call it
um mascot mascot should we apply to be
students also uc santa cruz is back to
school for some reason i know
it's very good they're increasingly
being
like a stoner school right a really fun
oh my god
i love it i just
those are really there's a cute one
there that one's kind of scary the honey
slugs is what they're called banana
slugs banana slices i know how accurate
is that
we gotta like get money from these
people they should be paying us that
doesn't seem right we should be there
although i will say annie is if i ever
pictured you in a university it would be
uc santa cruz why it is such like a cool
like stoner kind of like
creatives type of school that sounds
really fun i really need to go there we
got to get you high i got to go to
school get your nursing degree from
there
you know someone commented that like
they think i just want the prestige of
nursing school no i want the knowledge
is there a way to block comments from
master i can't allow you to keep reading
give them too much power i don't read
them i like will skim them but i do want
to clarify i really want the knowledge
of nursing soul but i don't probably
want to practice it it might make you um
more of a hypochondriac of course why
wait
no comfort i don't want to be like
worried about what i have what's going
to make you more worried oh really yeah
it's like everyone's like oh the more
you know
no that's not a good thing because then
you become like overly analytical like
me and so like i have to always like tie
it to something wrong i will not allow
you to be a nurse why is that legal yeah
i'm going to kidnap you
i'm going to beat you with a slug and a
banana
annie for your birthday i got you
something really special oh no
it's gonna be something goes in my ass
it's not oh i wish i wish it was
something like like a like a button
close your eyes close your eyes is it
alive
open your eyes and catch it
what is it oh i know this symbol
it's the hot and juicy symbol of my
favorite crab legs i think i think
that's enough
[Music]
that's gonna give me like a pound and a
half
oh my god i've never felt more rich in
my life wow how much do you think
that'll buy this will be okay if we get
what we usually get this will be three
trips
this is very exciting
this is probably gonna be two trips
honestly because we're gonna shove it in
this is very exciting that reaction
ah
this is what i bought myself i bought
myself my jordans oh those are cute
i'm sure i'm shaking this is the best
present it's ever given me
your presence is enough don't worry
just closed your legs birthday day
closed your legs that's all we needed
can we do a banana break
[Music]
wait i want a tiara
can we name it
for annie for her birthday of her own
face
he got to me he knows that
who loves this [ __ ] more than me
annie where are your
your tiara oh my god it's our clay
pictures whatever looks hotter than when
clayton photoshops us
the depression afterwards though is
really real what is that
doesn't that seem like a trick though
happy birthday
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear auntie is the joke
that it's filled with go go for esther
oh it looks like two titties it does
look like boobies one's a little bit
bigger than the other
birthday to you
oh it's so hard to make a wish when all
my wishes came true
[Music]
where did you where is that from
it's like from the grocery store it
looks very decadent
that's like no that will like ruin my
day i need that alone in a corner i've
only seen someone buy this for you at
you and make you eat it what do you mean
oh
my god oh my god
you guys know that pete does all his own
arts and crafts
he put the glue on the outside oh my god
you guys are absolutely out of these
cubes too
this is very beautiful
unfortunately this is so beautiful
unfortunately you have to wear it it
looks so pretty unfortunately
the we end the show forever
you might be the birthday girl annie but
she's the go-go queen
[Music]
how are you guys his armpits are so
white
your armpits you said you were gonna
smell our bo and see if we had it gladly
did you really move you said i don't
back i don't back away
it's already turning to hoagie oh that's
beautiful little [ __ ] rings
[ __ ] plain do you want us to come to
you or do you want to come here come to
me come to me one at a time
queen walk
it would be this it would be this
stop
oh my god you really are dressed like me
esther come lower esther's passing out
some boners today
okay it's a lot like there's something
there
you can't deny you're really getting in
but i like it what does it smell like it
smells natural oh mine's starting to you
can start to smell the hoagie underneath
i want to know how they compare do you
smell it i don't smell it
okay so here's my analysis
is that
yours actually smells perfumey but
that's because i put the i put the yeah
i don't smell any body odor
it's it's underneath esther
it's there is a natural body odor but
it's very attractive oh your family's
match your family i like it i like the
smell yeah of course it's because she's
she's attracted to bobby so me and bobby
are they bobby doesn't have any body
odor
zero i swear to you guys you can smell
his armpit any time of day and there's
just nothing do you want to smell mine
that doesn't smell like anything it's
boring wait maybe there is
annie yours is perfumey
it's just deodorant yours is musky but
in a good way
oh my god we're just so it smells so
beautiful we're just so hot
deodorant yeah i smell a mustache
esther's the only real lady
that like watched monster and looked up
to her
like that's what i want to look like
eileen warno's yeah she's just i don't
know why she wants to be so quick what
is that
it's another gift it's to give to esther
is it no this is for you oh no
this is george related isn't it what is
it
[Laughter]
what is it what is it remember when i
choked on a chicken sandwich they got me
a chicken deluxe and the highlight
maneuver
it's so cold i really would have enjoyed
eating this is it fresh peat
no this is a cup
it's two hours oh two hours not bad i
would say two days i was gonna throw up
on sight oh i'll gladly
let girl look like esther although
mcdonald's isn't that the food where
they did the experiment where if you
leave that cheeseburger out for like 30
years it doesn't change i thought i
would say esther eats it
really like it doesn't decay
that is are we [ __ ] up twinkies but i
don't know
oh it looks like it looks like esther's
choking then kalila cut her hair
short and is helping her wait you're
saying that mcdonald's is non-perishable
you wouldn't eat it but there was like
someone was selling it on ebay like
someone had
some kind of gross food that was
so preserved that it just didn't can i
guess what it was
was that one of the people that cleaned
your car out
my car is not that we're searching for
someone to take that job on
well it thank you guys for listening to
yet another week with another wild ride
oh wow was that your southern wow wow
um thank you guys for my birthday show
it was so fun happy birthday mr annie
thank you so much miss andrew actually
no to you please take a ton of pictures
when you eat those crab legs oh my god
are you kidding and send them to me do
you want to come with me all different
angles
you could also have caught them for me i
don't want to be rude but i can't i'm
not a crab catcher i'm a lobster catcher
well give me some lobsters
i know it's not crabs you're a crab leg
queen you're right slugs out there
please like this video subscribe to this
channel
give us a review on itunes share it post
it we will repost you we are really
trying to get the word out there that we
are the trashiest [ __ ] nastiest we
are the most beautiful pig pigs but also
kind of hot girls we'll see you guys
next week bye
[Music]
you